okay do you need to do some vocal
warm-ups to sit in solemn silence do you
know what that wasn't in solemn silence
on a dark dot in a pestilential prison
with a lifelong block awaiting the
sensation of a short sharp shock that
sounds like someone that's about to
commit suicide but loves theater no hi
my name is crystal baby no no no you
know your life it's different now cool
to see it happen in real life
yeah thank you Thanks this is Elliott
Morgan if you do not know yeah you know
in your life your life is probably think
a week or two ago we did a video on
Elliott's channel in which he asked me
to watch his stand-up special holy [ __ ]
now available and if you've heard of a
platform experience he asked me to watch
his stand-up special and then ask him
questions about it felt like I was doing
the heavy lifting for his YouTube videos
so I thought to kind of return the favor
I guess I would let Elliot ask me
anything and I tweeted out to you guys
to give him questions that he could ask
me in addition to whatever you want to
ask as yourself great another will come
out great in the Edit I don't have a
stand-up special that I'm promoting
because I think my whole life is just
one long comedy special got it let's
just get into this let's get into it
okay I will say I have given this very
little thought oh great because that's
how I prepared for your video I'm gonna
start with a question from myself how
has your day been I went to therapy
today so it's been very wonderful and
then I came home and I shot a hellofresh
video that you guys will see soon which
is why I'm a little bit tipsy and way
more open to shooting this video
currently in this moment so overall
great Sachi tilde Matilda asks me
Matilda D Matilda Matilda 3 now what is
therapy like you talking casually about
it brings me comfort when I
oh well it's like this
it's literally like this usually
especially your mom and dad it's great
you're also a very huge advocate of
therapy to have a sincere answer to this
is that one of the foundations of improv
that I love so dearly is follow your
fear when you're afraid of something
that means the year ultimately like
curious or want to be curious about it
and therapy usually is very terrifying
because I hold the mirror up to all the
things that you want to look at a brick
wall about wow I love you very much and
I would add that I think sometimes
people think therapy is a way of
bringing things together but oftentimes
it's a way of actually getting caring
everyone apart things get worse when you
do the right thing sometimes so what is
your favorite memory with mamrie and
Hannah I've had so many memories with
Hannah and mamrie I think my most recent
favorite memory was when we were just
recently in New York for the launch of
Hannah's book and we did a classic Thai
one on drink until 4:00 a.m. like
snuggle buddies in a hotel room just
like crying and loving each other and it
was very very sweet because we're all
adults now we're all going through adult
things
it was very nice and here is all of the
documentation that happened that night
just goose love Elliot more than Elliot
loves goose
it's like waves in the ocean sometimes
they go up sometimes they I think goose
probably does love me more I love goose
but that's only because goose hasn't
gone to enough therapy to actually she's
like jaws like jaws she is a lot like
job choice you have to believe like
actually love someone at some point and
like cared for some family member or
some love watch what jaws is so angry
because it's waiting it's like I had was
probably like
hasn't had any emotional connection and
so long and that's why that things
taking it out on the beats yeah and it
thinks that that's the way that it gets
love its just misunderstood
that's what goose is what's the proudest
you've been of Elliot slash yourself
oh those are two very different
questions the proudest is right now then
we're able to film a video like this and
not feel as awkward as we feel about
shooting a video like this together this
is a personal Elliot question yes what
is the question that you either do or do
not want me as your boyfriend Elliot to
ask you do you have any STDs Rosie
giving asks do you ever watch videos you
shot together before you were dating to
try to see if there was a vibe back then
no we do not marry social media
platforms so tick tock kill your answer
yeah why not I'll take the rings now I
guess I would kill something I don't use
which is snapchat
[Music]
yeah I like chick talk because it's
gonna be here for a second rich and
there's a lot of money real quick
jealous I know he's jealous of the
tic-tock that you wanted to kill I see I
would probably marry Instagram I guess
also because there's so many [ __ ]
wedding photos on Instagram to begin
with that your pre-programmed that you
should marry this source is that your
answer to would you I think tick-tock
might be the right answer you just said
you want to kill them right well those
go hand in hand if you want to talk what
board game do you hate the most
Asus Ryan I think the board game I hate
the most is monopoly okay but also
because I haven't played it in a long on
it
one more game do you hate the most I can
tell you which one I love the most
yeah I could tell you what I love the
most get will category yeah that's on a
board game that's not a board game game
well it's my answer and I mean
[Music]
a board game is a game with a board
categories I just feel like it should be
good at oh here's the one that I hate
the most
okay in talking about this don't wake
daddy that one makes me upset for dads
out there because it just sets kids up
to be like oh I have to sneak around if
dad wakes up out of bed we were playing
this game no no no no no no I haven't
thought about in probably 20 years but I
know what you're talking about
wait daddy yeah oh my god literally a
dad in bed right now I can see his he
has like a big nose he's wearing like a
very abusive father
you know channel but into making art as
anything surprised you about Elliott
that's a good I'm not I don't like the
question but I'm gonna ask it just to
see if something good could come from it
has anything ever in your life possibly
surprised you about me yeah Elliott
you're way less uptight than when I
thought you were when I first met you
what is Elliott's weirdest habit and
Grayson oh this is a question for both
of us did you want to answer for me go
ahead there's the whole like I sometimes
steal animals collars what what my
weirdest have it I've never dated or
known in Milan what did I eat cake icing
for your breakfast your taste buds are
in no way attuned to where the Sun is at
it could be 7:00 a.m.
and you'd be like I want sushi and I
think that's very fun but also we have
breakfast for dinner as this like
creative fun concept why don't we have
dinner for breakfast right is that in
the reverse so crazy but I want to keep
thinking about like it's so hard to
think of these so quickly what is the
weirdest thing that you do are you
shower all the time shower a lot o the
time shower it makes me feel awake and
you're like do you need to get the
shower and I'm like
for the third day in a row that's not no
I don't know that's on you if Greece
were condiment what would she be and why
thank you for asking Larissa and the
answer what's your answer grace what
would you be
oh this is a question for me well we're
it's you know what would you be if you
were economy and I'll answer after you
answer and I want to know if you have
the right this is where I have the right
answer I know exactly where you are look
great what would I be I mean would I be
as a condiment is the hardest one to
answer I don't think I would be knowing
that you know that you have the right
answer um just going through what is in
the refrigerator right now it's in there
it's in our fridge right right now let
me get it out no more say mayonnaise
because mayonnaise like is so polarized
like I would be something that's very
like mild but also there all the time
doesn't cause problems for people maybe
that's a ketchup maybe that's a mustard
maybe it's a salsa why is this the
hardest one to answer I actually spend
way too much time thinking about them
maybe that's like the most self-aware
thing I can answer is that I don't know
what condiment I would be yeah merchants
beautiful now and I show you can I can i
grab the condom please yeah close my
eyes am i relish oh and my [ __ ] relish
can I open I think mustard and you think
like bitter old it's over the flavor of
everything and very like Here I am
then you add the honey and you realize
that you're just sweet and you just you
make everything better and you're my
favorite thing to put chicken fingers on
and I mean that in every way Wow to put
chicken fingers in thank you so much for
being here thank you guys for watching
this video if you liked it give it a
thumbs up I don't give up we do or don't
but that's a cool thing please do
subscribe to this YouTube channel I
guess
can I make videos doesn't turn out to
deep every Monday and this make it weird
every Wednesday and also this bro has
new series on Facebook about called
ladies first where she interviews
incredibly influential women and I do
truly believe people should watch it and
I could not be prouder of this person
and she's the she's so wonderful all
right but I'm not joking and I'm serious
and do it I don't know can I hear what
your initial thoughts were on the ask of
this task I thought it was really sweet
[Laughter]
really I mean okay I was like hey I need
content I just did this video can you do
me a solid no we don't want to do the
thing where we're like you know making
videos together because people like
couples so we're just we're first and we
also were very good about keeping our
relationship off of social media yes